Alright, well this is Jack
as you know.
All right.
What up?
What are we doing at the sand pit?
Today I'm going to attempt the front flip.
And how do you do a front flip?
What is your technique?
My technique is I take about
a five to six meter run up
and then I jumped in the air,
go upside down,
and hopefully land on my feet.
Do you ever land like this?
We doing it on that one
or are we doing this sand pit as well?
We're doing both.
Take one.
Right well, I better give this a go then.
I think so.
This is not gonna go well.
All right, here I come.
Jack, do a back flip.
Yeah?
I've caught a front flip.
I guess bad flip is the next.
I'm not going to try this one.
I think you should.
Cause I like my neck.
Go for it.
Jack, I think we should give it one
of our world famous double Superman's.
What do you reckon?
Yeah?
All right, let's do it.
Oh, I landed on my feet.
All right there.
I'm just hijacking the
end of this video quickly.
Firstly, thanks to dr3adskull
for the suggestion for this video
and secondly,
due to the fact that
we've hit a million views,
I'm going to do a
question and answer video
because I get a lot of
questions in the comments
of these videos
which I've tried to answer,
but there's just so many
and the answers get lost and stuff.
So basically, if you
want to ask any question
about The Slow Mo Guys
put it in the comments of this
front flip back flip video
and there will be answered
in an upcoming video.
So well that's it,
Subscribe.